we got the story on jackpot thanks pozzo
bounding into comics reports
oan host jack posobic calls for boycott
of space jam a new legacy
after lebron james threatened police
i don't know if he's serious which is
funny i think he's joking but i love how
these tweets just end up getting news
coverage
so peace promoter poso is his name
boycott space jam lebron threatens
police
all right the call to boycott the film
comes after james posted a photo of a
cop on twitter
he captioned the photo writing your next
accountability
yikes james did delete his uh his tweet
as pacific points out he writes
hi lebron james why did you delete this
the photos of officer
nicholas written this we get all right
okay space jam a new legacy is being
distributed by eighteen t on warner
brothers blah blah blah
do plan on taking up posobik's call and
boycotting space jam a new legacy after
lebron james threatened
a columbus police officer who prevented
a stabbing i'm assuming they meant to
say do you plan to
right yeah i mean i just read the
articles as their percentage is copy
editing
yeah seriously give me a break i didn't
even know there was a space jam
happening this is the first i've heard
of it
why do i i don't want to watch it anyway
what is it a remake hold on i'm going to
pretend i want to watch it and say i'm
boycotting it
there you go i do want to watch space
jam i love the og space jam i'm a huge
fan of it actually
yeah no i i i had no plan on watching
this okay i'm not going to watch it
uh i wouldn't have watched it i'm not
going to watch
a boycott i'm back big fan of space jam
i didn't wash my hands that was
so bad so quick speed is of the essence
just
protect us yeah are you a space jam fan
no man did you see the first one michael
jordan and bugs bunny yeah yeah
oh come on grow up silly yeah um
so that were they remaking the original
or sorry oh that's right you were
children when that came out yeah yes it
was good okay
of course you loved it when this came
out and they had they had the burger
king cups or whatever
yeah what was it they had like the glass
jar yeah it was fun
and i would i would uh i was so excited
to go see that in the movies
i think it was like 40 years old yeah i
was like yeah you're like
nah you must have been in your no you
must've been 93 or something yeah i was
like 94.
94. it was i was just at the age where i
could realize it was like
really cheap propaganda it just seemed
like propaganda just seemed like
what they were using a basketball player
to sell a product
what wasn't like a movie he wasn't a
good actor michael jordan
oh you're stuck you're saying that they
put them in a movie for the sake of
selling tickets to a movie yeah
yeah yeah but i thought it was kind of
cool but i didn't see the movie that
they took
sort of like this the mary poppins
model and brought it back with michael
jordan yeah you take animation
yeah and in real because that's not
really who framed roger rabbit was in
that time
yeah i remember that exactly so they
reinvented a genre
so this one is just a it's just how much
money you need
it was really high budget too you know
you know this is four
they're trying to target people like
between my age and ian's age
who have kids who are going to be like
who loved it i remember space jam i want
to take my kids to see space jam
this is an example of cultural decay
no no heavy hold
give me a more modern christmas song um
i'm
dreaming what year was that song let me
finish
christmas uh 1945.
yeah can you try another more modern
christmas song oh uh
santa got run over by rain hey what year
was that
60s yeah so how come i can keep going
we we i think i think the most modern i
can think of is all i want for christmas
is you by the way
but
from the 60s really really old we're not
writing new music
our movies are regurgitations it's not
changing we're not making new things
we're not inspiring people
we are just saying i'm gonna do what i
did when when i was a kid again with my
kids
instead of hey let's write a new concept
a new movie a new song let's
let's change it up we're stagnating
exact culture is decaying
when's the last great uh protest song
since
kendrick lamar i mean you know look
we're living in it where's the music man
it's too corny in court where's the
writing bro bro when when
when the biggest protest moves hold on
hold on
when the biggest protest movement is on
the same side as walmart
and amazon right i don't think those are
protest songs right
i think those are corporate jingles yeah
i wrote a
christmas song it's called it's
christmas time it's on youtube
um that's it and hum a few bucks i wrote
it ian wrote it it's christmas time
something something song you don't even
know you're wrong
i haven't listened to it like 12 years
but i wrote it it's it's
it's too it could be refined i'll say
this i'll say this
don't boycott space jam because lebron
james tweeted something dumb
boycott regurgitations demand something
new
thank you or you know what
maybe check it out when it comes to
netflix i mean i'm i'm
not going to be able to watch no no
netflix doesn't do that anymore okay but
you know
well i guess it'll come out of netflix
check it out and tell everybody else it
sucks
look i'm a sucker i still get kentucky
fried chicken i will go to taco bell
wait are they sponsors of the show no i
won't go to taco
i'll go back to taco bell once you
sponsor this show but
i do do that i'm not a purist yeah
sometimes you got to use the corrupt
system to fix the corruption i'm part of
it man no no no we're
you're making something new you're doing
the no bs newshour
you got something new we're doing
something new we are going to hook
funding
shows we should hook up we should you
want to do news let me know and we'll
we'll get some good news going on yeah
we're going to do news we're going to do
shows we're going to do comedy we're
going to do movies we're going to do
sci-fi
because i'm because i'm sick and tired
of every single thing
it's been years man since what was
you know what i like the marvel
cinematic universe the superhero movies
yeah but come on they're just making
movies out of comics from 70 years ago
yeah
yeah but at least i don't got to read
them now sure sure
it's it's a great modern adaptation of
something that's really really old
at a certain point stan lee jack kirby
these guys were like how about a guy who
turns green and gets real strong when
he's mad
well actually i think he originally
turned gray but you know you get the
point how about a guy who can jump over
tall buildings and for some reason he
has like eyes breath
it was they made something up and they
worked on it it became popular because
they worked on it
now everybody is just trying to say i
don't want to do the work i want what
he's got
let me inherit your wealth and i'm not
going to make something new
these companies don't want to take the
risks they don't want to make new
exciting things because it's a
it's a potential risk i got one i got
one yeah
christmas old movies being made into new
movies
old books right maybe why can't we get a
new
ten commandments oh i'm so excited i
like that movie
yeah yeah the movie ten commandments
yeah i do charlton has found
the ten commandments oh remake i thought
you meant to actually write ten new
commandments
okay that works too yeah that is i think
more even more important i don't know
about that we'll discuss it look at the
manila
amendments yeah the manila principles
that could be a pretty sweet i would
love to play that role you
you look like you're getting the redoing
doom wait jesus doesn't come till later
moses says listen i want to ask you
something jesus when did you get
white uh it took about 2000 years
from what i heard it took the romans
yeah that's right they're they're
they're redoing dune ian's really
excited for that oh dude yes
dude oh yeah but i heard it might be
woke um oh really
yeah i don't know many details did you
read it
wait is that the one it was like a
famous 80s isn't it yeah yeah early 80s
uh lynch did one david lynch did it
wasn't it the dude from the police uh
i don't know yeah sting was in it sting
big flap yeah he was actually really
good in that
it was a weird lynch movie but sting was
awesome was it a big flap
it was yeah they tried they gave they
did monologues like long
monologues which don't translate to film
they're good in theater and in books
they make a lot of sense but not
they were they were doing inner inner
monologues yeah it was really really
weird
just show his face and he's thinking and
you hear his voice for like
three minutes it's so boring yeah they
tried to make a
book into a movie without making it a
movie and then in the 90s they did one
with william hurt
and dune made for tv movie but they
translated all that monologue into
dialogue and it made it way
more interesting we just need new stuff
that's what we're doing oh so we we we
put our vlog got
age restrictions yes what's up with that
what adrien's what happened what
we made we made a vlog from the house
showing people the house
because the point is one of the things
i'm big on is we got to make culture
which means you can't just sit around
and complain about politics because
politics
is downstream from culture right now you
need to make stuff to inspire people
and build community and so i'm like
we're going to do that we're going to
start a vlog we started vlog
we got this probably showing this joint
yeah yeah yeah so we got the ramps we
got the outside
no this place is a trip totally no you
walk in here unexpected i walked in
today like
what the hell is going on it's great
everybody their their computers going up
they're
they're finding your ipn they're doing
ibm
they're talking about dracula i mean
it's like what we launched
we got bows and arrows outside we
launched race cars over the garage
and we put up this vlog and youtube age
restricted it no you can't you can't
you can't oh we're not showing that no
you can't it's not
real as far as you know youtube so
uh it's an antique that's not an antique
what's not an answer that's real what it
is
so we have a vlog that age restricted it
and so that's i guess
that's that's that's i just particularly
annoying i thought what does it mean
exactly you have to be signed in 18
years old to watch the vlog
and that's because they think that's
actually kind of cool no it's bad it
means you can't put on other websites
and you can't share it
okay but you're creating the new culture
so you know what
if what that vlog is saying is for real
come find it just lean into it yeah
maybe we can't make it easy for you
give some effort right that's why they
put a restriction on it because they
don't want
us to actually influence people to be
free independent thinkers who want to
build and create and inspire others
that's why i don't mind people taking to
the streets man just don't tear it up
i agree man peaceful protest somebody
mess with you drop them
i mean i think would be peaceful be
disruptive but not violent not
destructive
disruptive means like you kind of annoy
people when you're marching down the
street and you're kind of you know in
the way a little bit
it work it worked with mlk and it worked
with gandhi
mlk got things a lot farther than what
malcolm x
is saying but never doing they burn they
they set buildings on fire they cost two
billion dollars in in
damage and they got their conviction and
the insurance company you know the old
argument
no no no the the buildings in
minneapolis couldn't be rebuilt because
the cost of rubble removal exceeded the
the the liability insurance coverage
well it's funny one of the billion i
won't name the companies but one of the
buildings they got torn up
got a sweet deal a sweet package
sweet tax abatements and subsidies
from the city of minneapolis to build
it's a multinational
yeah why is why are we doing that
how did this happen correct a main line
to the mayor's ear
well it's become american culture now
i'll leave if you don't give me
your children's breakfast you know
my child's school my child you know we
do okay so my child doesn't get the
federal breakfast program
but i'm an elder i'm a man of this
community i go see we're defeating the
kids
generic pop tarts and orange drink
our money now i am not i think
we all have to feed our children
right i'm not gonna feed your dad for
his whole life but the kid ain't going
hungry
not as long as i'm living on the earth
how is it i paid you reached in my
pocket
for orange juice it went to washington
it went to lansing it went to the school
board
and magically my tax money for that
child
the orange juice transmogrified into
orange
drink some contract yes
it's like food coloring sugar and
vitamin c
so it's okay it's they were supposed to
buy orange juice
that's what i bought orange drinks why
are we feeding our kids
orange drink and generic pop-tarts when
you could be giving them
uh biotrust
in hospitals they fed patients healthy
food instead of
amazing instead of sweet drink yeah it's
they think about
a hospital a place of healing and they
they feed people the same kind of stuff
they feed in public schools
where do money go there are a lot of
rich people
eating a lot of fancy meals i'll tell
you that a lot of blue coat
media sitting down public officials
being stenographers for them and having
fancy dinners you know i love about the
media that hangs out with the swells
they think they're a swell they also
think they're a swell
but you know what i always say you're a
you're a
hound you're a poodle laying at the
table waiting for a scrap to fall off
ain't nobody's listening to you not when
the times get real
you think they are anybody out there
reading the local business magazine
yeah i think uh
just to just to cycle back that the
sugar industry
is subsidizing like the government in
such a way that they're pumping sugar
into the schools
and the hospitals and the prisons and
that's why we see orange drink there's
some contractor isn't there
there's always a contractor thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time